Intermountain Healthcare the sponsors of
this segment is back to educate older
adults on the effects and prevention of
osteoporosis
just Anita Culver I'm here with
Intermountain Healthcare My Generation
clinics here at Green Valley we're here
today to talk about osteoporosis
osteoporosis is a condition that occurs
mainly as we get older where it causes
our bones to become very brittle and at
risk of breaking very easily so
researchers estimate one out of every
five women over the age of 50 already
have osteoporosis women are at higher
risk of being affected than men but men
are effective as well so risk factors of
osteoporosis include Advanced age so as
we get older we're more inept to get it
women are more at risk than men but
again certain things can change that and
men can be at higher risk as well other
things are a sedentary lifestyle like
not exercising as much some other
factors include cigarette smoking
increased alcohol intake and alcohol
would be more than two drinks a day
every single day some other risk factors
are a small body frame
race as far as you know our white and
Asian races are at higher risk
as well as decrease of certain
nutritional aspects like calcium and
vitamin D things to look out for if you
develop osteoporosis some people can
develop pain from a broken bone in the
back or someplace that they didn't
intend you can get loss of height you
can get a souped posture also you'll
real you can break a bone very easily
when you would have thought you would
have not have now remember there's no
early signs of osteoporosis a lot of
this happens when our bones weaken
talking about some things with
prevention sedentary lifestyle is one of
the things that is a risk factor but one
of the things that we can also do to
make it better exercise is a huge way to
improve your risk of developing
osteoporosis and or increase fractures
simple things like walking
weight-bearing exercises like walking
with small weights as well as balance
exercises like Tai Chi can really help
prevent things like osteoporosis from
progressing here at intermountains my
generation clinics we do specialize in
senior care we do offer a lot of classes
for our seniors including things like
Tai Chi balance strength training to
help prevent osteoporosis unfortunately
a lot of our patients will have a simple
fall and have a broken hip or broken
wrist that we have to rehab so to help
prevent that we do have a lot of
processes in place like exercise classes
so high impact exercises have not shown
major gains in bone mineral density and
post-menopausal women but weight-bearing
endurance exercises 30 to 60 Minutes
three to five times per week is more
beneficial strength training to load the
spine and hip area is recommended three
days per week these weight-bearing
exercises could include leg press leg
extension leg curls squats loaded back
extensions with shoulders and arm
exercises so it's a good idea to check
with your healthcare provider to see
what the best options are for prevention
and treatment of osteoporosis here at
Intermountain Healthcare My Generation
clinics we are accepting patients at our
30 locations please reach out to us and
give us a call
for more information you can go to
intermountainhealthcare.org Nevada we'll
be back